this is the call that started it all  when my mom went into the hospital for a  routine partial hip replacement a new  something was wrong  the neurologist called us my mom is in a  coma and now it's brutally clear I need  a lawyer we have not even begin to  recognize the country's third leading  cause of death medical care gone wrong  the medical profession needs to be  accountable for the errors these are our  costs 421 thousand dollars meds health  insurance taxes all roads lead to the  insurance company their whole plan is to  drag this out as long as they can  your lawyer my crack know I'm a comedy  director this is taken over our lives  problems in health care continue to be  endemic we are not learning from our  mistakes something has to change this  doesn't keep happening to people  you